well let me ask about jfk
[Laughter]
25 times two
and they still keep that stuff
classified
so
do you think
the cia had a hand in the assassination
of jfk
i cannot imagine
in any reasonable point of view that the
organization of cia had anything to do
with the assassination of jfk so it's
not possible to infiltrate
the cia
a small part of the say in order to
attain political or criminal
gains i think financial yeah absolutely
it's possible to infiltrate cia there's
a long history of
of foreign intelligence services
infiltrating cia from aldrich aims to
uh jerry lee recently with china so we
know cia can be infiltrated
uh
even if they are infiltrated and even if
that interlocutor
executes on
their own agenda or their the agenda as
directed by their foreign adversary
their foreign handler
that's different than organizational
support for an event
so i do
think it's possible they could have been
infiltrated at the time especially it
was a massive
a major priority for the cubans and the
russians
to infiltrate some aspect of of uh us
intelligence multiple
moles were caught in the years following
so it's it's not surprising that there
would be a priority for that but to say
that the organization of cia was somehow
in cahoots
with to independently assassinate their
own executive
that's a significant stretch i've seen
no evidence to support that and it goes
contrary to everything i learned from my
time at cia
you